Well, I'm sold.
Libraries are great.
There are certainly some
downsides to be aware of.
By definition,
a library is reusable and generic.
If it custom built for you app,
it would be easier to call it your code.
That means that libraries may
include more than what you need and
bloat what could be a lean app, or
maybe not even cover the cases you need.
And of course,
libraries are built by developers and
that means there may be bugs,
architectures that don't work well with
your existing app, or trade-offs such as
quality versus memory consumption that
you might not be able to control.
In addition,
not every library ages gracefully.
They may not be taking
advantages of the newest API's,
hampering your ability to build
the best user experience.
Or they may have been
abandoned entirely,
leaving you stranded when
faced with an issue or a bug.
Goes to show picking the right library
might be the most important step.